[Música]
Rusia bombardea masivamente Ucrania las
fuerzas de Moscú lanzaron 81 misiles
contra
kievsan al entre otras ciudades el
kremlin defiende que se trató de ataques
de precisión como respuesta a la
explosión en el puente de crimea se
cuentan hasta el momento 11 muertas y
decenas de heridos civiles
el coletazo del huracán Julia causó
desbordamientos de ríos y quebradas que
dejan al menos 25 muertos y más de 50
desaparecidos en las tejerías en
Venezuela el presidente Nicolás Maduro
decretó el estado de catástrofe natural
y ahora convertida en depresión tropical
Julia llegó a Guatemala tras devastar
otros países de Centroamérica Tenemos
reporte
recibieron el Nobel de economía 2022
según la academia sueca los premiados
ayudaron a comprender el papel de los
bancos en la economía de Mercado
particularmente durante las crisis
financieras
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
de la guerra en Ucrania porque Rusia
escaló su ofensiva sobre Ucrania en
horas de la mañana de Europa las fuerzas
de Moscú bombardearon masivamente el
territorio ucraniano de norte a sur y de
este a oeste el ejército ruso disparó 81
misiles sobre kiev el VIP hardkivs
saporiya jerson y nikolaive entre otras
ciudades el kremlin defendió que los
bombardeos son una respuesta a la
explosión en el puente de crimea de este
sábado incidente del que Moscú acusa
kiev Putin habló de ataques de precisión
sin embargo se cuentan al menos 11
muertos y decenas de heridos civiles
Juan pupiales con los detalles
es revivir lo más crudo de la Guerra el
centro de kiev volvió a hacer este lunes
objetivo de un bombardeo un ataque que
se extendió por horas y que es el
primero contra la capital desde que el
kremlin desistió en su intento de tomar
esta ciudad nos despertamos esta mañana
con este saludo por parte de nuestros
vecinos usted verá esto aquí y por toda
la ciudad
al menos otras seis ciudades también han
reportado tales bombardeos desde el VIP
a lo bestia hasta harkkin en pro y
saporiya en el este En esta última urbe
los bombardeos golpearon zonas
residenciales como esta para el
presidente de Ucrania el objetivo de
Moscú es claro pone para España quieren
pánico y caos quieren destruir nuestro
sistema de energía no tienen remedio el
segundo objetivo son las personas y esos
objetivos fueron elegidos especialmente
para causar el mayor daño posible el
presidente Vladimir Putin reconoció la
ofensiva aseguró que su respuesta a la
explosión que afectó este fin de semana
a un entre Rusia y la Península
anexionada de crimea se trata de un
ataque que kiev no ha reconocido pero sí
lo celebró Dame según los datos forenses
y de otros expertos así como la
información de inteligencia muestra que
la explosión del 8 de octubre fue un
ataque terrorista un ataque que tiene
como objetivo destruir la
infraestructura civil crítica rusa
Moscú también celebró haber golpeado
todos los objetivos designados este
lunes además con la promesa de Putin de
una respuesta dura si continúan los
ataques desde Ucrania
y precisamente la comunidad
internacional condenó enseguida los
nuevos ataques rusos contra Ucrania el
secretario general de la otan jensen
stoltenberg calificó los bombardeos de
horribles e indiscriminados la comisión
europea habló de crímenes de guerra y el
presidente de Estados Unidos joeyden
dijo que son una muestra de la
brutalidad de Putin Marta Moya con la
reacciones Internacionales
La frágil sensación de normalidad en
múltiples ciudades ucranianas lejos de
los frentes de batalla terminó
repentinamente las condenas a los
últimos ataques contra la
infraestructura civil se han sucedido en
la Esfera europea una vez más Rusia ha
mostrado al mundo lo que representa es
el terror y la brutalidad la Unión
Europea dice que el ataque
indiscriminado a civiles equivale a un
crimen de guerra y algunos estados
miembros como Estonia y lituania
reiteran que no es el momento de dar
marcha atrás ante Rusia
cada vez que alguien piensa tenemos que
ayudar a Putin para salvarle la cara y
darle algo para que no haga una
estupidez eso solo le anima a seguir
avanzando porque se toma Este
apaciguamiento como un signo de
debilidad
lo que tenemos que hacer es proporcionar
defensa aérea desde al lado Aliado para
que los ucranianos puedan proteger sus
ciudades porque Rusia está
definitivamente escalando para dañar a
los civiles
el presidente francés Emmanuel maccón
reafirmó el apoyo militar al gobierno
ucraniano y expresó su preocupación
los ataques deliberados de Rusia en todo
el territorio ucraniano y contra la
población civil es un cambio profundo en
la naturaleza de esta guerra el
presidente de Ucrania también mantuvo
conversaciones con el canciller alemán y
pidió una respuesta unida y dura se ha
programado una reunión virtual de
emergencia del g7 para el martes en la
que intervendrá bolodimirselenski
por otro lado el presidente de belaruz
Alexander lukashenko acusó a Ucrania
Polonia y lituania de estar
supuestamente preparando ataques contra
su país el mandatario señaló haber
ordenado el despliegue de tropas junto
con Rusia cerca de Ucrania en respuesta
a esta supuesta amenaza escuchemos
los líderes militares y políticos de la
otan y varios países europeos están
considerando abiertamente opciones de
una posible agresión contra nuestro país
incluido un ataque nuclear Polonia
simplemente está temblando y está
pidiendo a los estadounidenses que
traigan armas nucleares de inmediato y
las desplieguen en Polonia
vamos ahora con información de nuestra
región después de causar al menos tres
muertes en Honduras y de haber devastado
parte de Nicaragua ahora convertida en
depresión tropical llegó a Guatemala el
fenómeno climático deja más de 150.000
afectados en este país desde donde nos
reportó nuestro corresponsal Andrés
Suárez Jaramillo
aquí en Guatemala las lluvias no han
cesado Desde la madrugada De este lunes
territorio guatemalteco donde ya ingresó
la tormenta Julia degradada como
depresión tropical de acuerdo con el
Centro Nacional de Huracanes de los
Estados Unidos sin embargo Aunque este
fenómeno metereológico sus vientos ya
hayan descendido a 56 kilómetros por
hora el nivel de precipitaciones
preocupa porque ya hay decenas de
municipios incomunicados deslaves Ríos
inundados Por lo cual fue activado el
protocolo de evacuaciones están
canceladas las clases y el sistema de
atención a desastres está pendiente de
lo que pueda llegar a ocurrir este lunes
en cuanto al Salvador de donde proviene
la tormenta por la costa del Pacífico la
Policía Nacional de este país ha
anunciado la muerte de dos personas en
un municipio del oriente luego del
derrumbe de varios muros y al parecer
una tercera estaría también sepultada
Honduras por su parte que es un país
centroamericano por donde no atravesó la
tormenta directamente ha sido ha
resultado uno de los más afectados
riadas intensas desbordamientos de ríos
provocaron el ahogamiento de tres
personas centenares de familias
afectadas y Se presume además Fuentes
extraoficiales dicen que una embarcación
de siete personas estaría desaparecida
y continuamos con información de la
depresión tropical Julia Porque el
coletazo de este fenómeno en Venezuela
causó al menos 25 muertos y 52
desaparecidos como consecuencia del
desbordamiento de ríos y quebradas la
vicepresidenta de Venezuela delsy
Rodríguez informó que el sábado por la
noche cayó tanta lluvia como la que se
puede precipitar en todo un mes el agua
arrastró troncos y escombros sobre la
comunidad de las tejerías en el estado
de aragua a unos 70 kilómetros de la
capital Caracas los daños materiales
afectaron negocios viviendas tierras de
cultivo y bombas de agua potable
situación
y hay personas tapiadas ahí que nos han
encontrado necesitamos ayuda que por
favor que esa invoque a ayudar a sacar a
las personas que están enterradas porque
no sabemos si hay personas enterradas en
un hermano desaparecido
necesitamos apoyo Pues bien el dolor del
pueblo porque no nada más el mío el
dolor todo el pueblo que está aquí
metido y Ben bernalquis Douglas Diamond
y Phillips recibieron el premio Nobel de
economía 2022 por sus extensas
investigaciones sobre los bancos y las
crisis financieras La Academia sueca
explicó que los premiados sentaron las
bases de como el mundo gestiona ahora
crisis globales como la pandemia de Kobe
19 o la gran recesión de 2008 Daniela
Blandón con los detalles
el mundo entero padeció los efectos de
una recesión financiera Global en 2008 y
2009 pero bembernky la sufrió en carne
propia como presidente de la reserva
Federal entre 2006 y 2014 halló una
oportunidad de oro para aplicar sus
investigaciones previas sobre la
recesión mundial de 1930 que hoy lo
llevan a recibir el premio Nobel de
economía junto con Douglas Diamond Y
Felipe David
En un artículo de 1983 mostró con
análisis estadísticos y fuentes
históricas que las corridas bancarias
condujeron a quiebras y este fue el
mecanismo que convirtió una recesión
relativamente ordinaria en la depresión
de los años 30 las corridas bancarias
son retiros masivos de dinero que llevan
al colapso de los bancos Las
investigaciones de los laureados según
la academia sueca ayudaron a demostrar
como un rescate bancario en momentos de
crisis es clave para evitar colapsos
peores
en 2008 la gente entendió que parte de
lo que sucedió después de la quiebra de
Brothers fue que hubo pánico un miedo al
miedo en sí mismo y que la respuesta
para recuperar la confianza fue
importante para enfrentar esa crisis
los gobiernos de casi todo el mundo
rescataron a los bancos en 2008 lo que
generó un torrente de críticas debido a
que muchos consumidores sufrieron y
perdieron sus hogares mientras los
bancos se salvaban y sin duda lo que
pasó en el 2008 en Estados Unidos que
generaba una crisis financiera global
tuvo mucho que ver con comportamientos
poco prudentes de parte de los bancarios
y en algunos casos incluso delitos y eso
fue todo procesado en su momento y
también generó un cambio en La
regulación de parte de la reserva
Federal los tres economistas recibirán
lo equivalente a 885 mil dólares en
coronas suecas por haber logrado un
galardón que ha llegado a muchos
estadounidenses y solo a dos mujeres en
la historia
y con este reporte que nos explicaba las
razones detrás de este Premio Nobel de
economía 2022 un reporte realizado por
nuestra periodista económica Daniela
brandón cerramos esta edición pero
recuerden pueden ampliar toda esta y más
información en nuestra página web France
24.com en nuestras redes sociales y por
supuesto sigan con nosotros enseguida
volvemos
[Música]